Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I had already concluded my letter when I gathered from various reports, as well as the hasty running of the people, that the great master of heretics was making his entrance. I sent one of my people out, and he told me that about a hundred mounted soldiers had escorted him to the gate of the city. Sitting in a coach with three comrades, he entered the city at ten in the morning,
感谢您收听《历史就是如此》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我写完这封信时，从各种报告以及人们匆忙奔走的情况中得知，那位异端大师正在入城。我派了手下出去，他告诉我，大约有一百名骑兵护送他到了城门口。他与三名同伴坐在马车里，于上午十点进入城内，
surrounded by some eight horsemen, and found lodgings near his Saxon prince. When he left the coach, a priest embraced him and touched his habit three times and shouted with joy, as if he had the relic of the greatest saint in his hands. I suspect he will soon be said to work miracles. This Luther, as he climbed from the coach, looked around in the circle with his demonic eyes, and he said, God will be with me. Then he stepped into an inn, where he was visited by many men, ten or twelve of which he ate with, and after the meal all the world ran there to see him. So Tom, that was Hieronymus Alexander, the papal legate, and he was reporting on Martin Luther's arrival in the city of Worms, which was the city on the banks of the Rhine, on the 16th of April, 1521.
周围簇拥着大约八名骑兵，并在他的萨克森亲王附近找到了住处。当他下车时，一位牧师拥抱了他，三次触摸他的法衣，并欢呼雀跃，仿佛手中握着最伟大圣人的遗物。我怀疑很快就会有人说他能行神迹。这位路德在下车时，用他那恶魔般的眼睛环顾四周，说道：“上帝会与我同在。”随后他走进一家旅店，许多人前来拜访他，他与其中十或十二人共进晚餐，饭后全世界的人都跑去见他。所以汤姆，那是教皇使节希罗尼穆斯·亚历山大，他正在报告马丁·路德抵达沃尔姆斯的情况，那是莱茵河畔的一座城市，时间是1521年4月16日。
The funny thing about that passage, I mean, when you read it, it's very kind of a Pharisee describes the coming of Jesus, isn't it? I mean, the 12 people eating with him. It's remarkable that Hieronymus Alexander did not notice the parallel hanging there in the air, or maybe he did? Well, as we'll find out, Luther gets given excellent accommodation in verbs, and Alexander doesn't. And it may be that he's a bit cross about the discrepancy in accommodation that's going on.
关于那段文字有趣的地方在于，当你读它时，它非常像法利赛人描述耶稣的到来，不是吗？我是说，那12个人和他一起吃饭。希罗尼穆斯·亚历山大竟然没有注意到其中悬而未决的相似之处，这很了不起，或者也许他注意到了？好吧，正如我们将要发现的，路德在沃尔姆斯得到了极好的住宿，而亚历山大却没有。他可能对这种住宿上的差异感到有些不满。
But this is one of the great scenes in European history, isn't it? And as you said yesterday, to English english speakers it's always been a cause of amusement the diet of worms so a diet is a kind of it's an assembly of the various leaders from across the empire who get summoned by the emperor himself but obviously the idea of eating worms i mean we in our chocolate episode we talked about how in the 17th century it was recommended that you should add worms to chocolate. Gaul of eel. Gaul of eel. Yeah.
但这确实是欧洲历史上最伟大的场景之一，不是吗？正如你昨天所说，对于讲英语的人来说，沃尔姆斯帝国会议（Diet of Worms）一直是一个笑料，因为“Diet”是一种来自帝国各地、由皇帝亲自召集的各种领导人的会议，但显然“吃虫子”（eating worms）这个想法……我们在巧克力那一集中谈到过，17世纪时有人建议在巧克力中加入虫子。鳗鱼胆。鳗鱼胆。是的。
But worms particularly. And more recently, the gravel-voiced manager of Everton Football Club, Sean Dyche. He called a press conference, didn't he? For the record, I definitely don't eat worms. He did. Our producer, Tony, told us that... Great anecdote about him. Well, because he was the manager of Burnley at the time when he made this.
但特别是虫子。最近，埃弗顿足球俱乐部那位嗓音沙哑的经理肖恩·戴奇。他召开了新闻发布会，不是吗？郑重声明，我绝对不吃虫子。他确实说了。我们的制片人托尼告诉我们……关于他的精彩轶事。好吧，因为他在发表这个声明时是伯恩利的经理。
Yeah, and Tony is a Burnley fan. He said that Sean Dyche, a superstition, a ritual of his, that after every match, he stops at McDonald's for a coffee. Tony thought this was an absolutely extraordinary detail, but we didn't greet it with the rapture and excitement that he was hoping for. Yeah, because if he'd stopped for coffee and a lot of worms, please, that would have been interesting. But anyway, listen, let's not get sidetracked.
是的，托尼是伯恩利的球迷。他说肖恩·戴奇有一个迷信，一个他的仪式，就是每场比赛后，他都会在麦当劳停下来喝杯咖啡。托尼认为这是一个绝对非凡的细节，但我们并没有像他希望的那样以狂喜和兴奋来回应。是的，因为如果他停下来是为了咖啡和“请给我来点虫子”，那会很有趣。但无论如何，听着，我们别跑题了。
So, Tom, let's just put this into context, because last week we talked about the rise of Martin Luther from obscurity to European celebrity, so European fame. This monk born in 1483, who either does or does not nail his attack on indulgences to the door of the church in Wittenberg. There's then a series of confrontations and debates with representatives of Catholic orthodoxy, if that's not a contradiction to that, where he's going further and further and becoming more and more radical in his attack on the establishment. He has gone through, we talked last time, he's gone through this almost kind of conversion experience, the experience of being born again, his reformation moment, as it is called, where he becomes convinced that only through the experience of the Bible and through faith alone can you achieve salvation.
所以，汤姆，让我们把这放在背景中，因为上周我们谈到了马丁·路德从默默无闻到欧洲名人的崛起，也就是欧洲声望。这位出生于1483年的僧侣，他要么钉了、要么没钉那份对维滕贝格教堂大门上赎罪券的抨击。随后发生了一系列与天主教正统代表的对抗和辩论——如果这不算矛盾的话——他在其中走得越来越远，在对建制的抨击中变得越来越激进。他经历过——我们上次谈到过——他经历过这种近乎皈依的体验，那种重生的体验，也就是所谓的宗教改革时刻，他确信只有通过圣经的体验和唯独信心，才能获得救赎。
And now we are heading for one of history's titanic confrontations, a great showdown. So it's two years, as you say in your notes here, so it's two years after another showdown we talked about, which was that between Hernan Cortes and the Aztec emperor Montezuma outside Tenochtitlan on the causeway. This is two years later, but arguably this is, I mean, it's less dramatic, but it's, would you argue it's more important or as important maybe? The meeting of Cortés and Montezuma is symbolically important for what it portends. But I think the meeting here, I mean, it really
现在我们正走向历史上最伟大的对抗之一，一场大决战。正如你在笔记中所说，这是在我们要谈论的另一场决战两年后，也就是埃尔南·科尔特斯与阿兹特克皇帝蒙特祖马在特诺奇蒂特兰堤道上的对峙。这是两年后，但可以说，我是说，它虽然没那么戏剧性，但你会认为它更重要，或者也许同样重要吗？科尔特斯和蒙特祖马的会面对于它所预示的事情具有象征意义。但我认为这里的会面，我是说，它确实
matters what the result of it is. And the meeting of the old world and the new is obviously off the scale in terms of the strangeness of it. But there is a strangeness here as well, because Luther, as well as being a condemned heretic, I mean, he is also a very humble stock. He is from a humble mining village. His ancestors are peasants. And the emperor, Charles V, is a Habsburg, and he is the ruler of probably the largest empire the world, certainly the European world, has seen. Because he's got all these vast European possessions. He's the Holy Roman Emperor. He's got Spain. He's got the Netherlands. He's got all kinds of stuff. But he's also getting this empire in the New World. Yeah.
结果如何至关重要。旧世界和新世界的会面在陌生程度上显然是超乎寻常的。但这里也有某种陌生感，因为路德不仅是一个被定罪的异端，而且他出身非常卑微。他来自一个卑微的矿工村。他的祖先是农民。而皇帝查理五世是哈布斯堡家族的人，他可能是世界上——当然是欧洲世界——所见过的最大帝国的统治者。因为他拥有所有这些广阔的欧洲领地。他是神圣罗马帝国皇帝。他拥有西班牙。他拥有荷兰。他拥有各种各样的东西。但他也在新世界获得了这个帝国。是的。
So it is an amazing moment. But it's also, it really matters in the history of the Reformation because Luther, by this point, is the most famous man in Germany. He is the star professor at the University of Wittenberg. And the question now is what is going to be done with him. He's been condemned, but it seems that the mass of German opinion is on his side. And more germainly, a key figure in the politics of the empire is on his side. And that is Frederick the Wise, the Elector of Saxony. And he is the man who has founded Wittenberg University,
所以这是一个了不起的时刻。但它在宗教改革史上也确实很重要，因为路德此时已是德国最著名的人。他是维滕贝格大学的明星教授。现在的问题是要如何处置他。他已经被定罪，但似乎德国的大多数舆论都站在他这一边。更贴切地说，帝国政治中的一个关键人物站在他这一边。那就是萨克森选侯“智者”腓特烈。他就是创办维滕贝格大学的人，
and he doesn't want to see his star professor literally go up in smoke. And so he is the one who negotiates to have Luther's case heard not in Rome, where he would undoubtedly be condemned and burned, but in Germany, and to have it heard not by the representatives of the church itself, but by the emperor. And listeners may be wondering, well, how is he able to force this through? And the answer is that Frederick is in a very strong position. So we talked about how he is one of the seven electors. And Charles, he was elected in the summer of 1519 and was elected unanimously. And that really, really mattered. And Frederick had held his cards close to his chest. He hadn't revealed until the last moment who he was going to vote for. And so,
他不想看到他的明星教授真的化为灰烬。所以他就是那个谈判让路德的案件不在罗马审理——在那里他无疑会被定罪并烧死——而是在德国审理，并且不是由教会本身的代表审理，而是由皇帝审理的人。听众可能想知道，好吧，他是如何强行推动这一点的？答案是腓特烈处于一个非常强势的地位。所以我们谈到了他是七位选侯之一。而查理，他在1519年夏天被一致推选。这真的、真的很重要。腓特烈一直守口如瓶。直到最后一刻，他都没有透露他要投票给谁。所以，
you know, Charles feels in his debt. And the evidence of this is that money starts to flow into Frederick's coffers. I mean, whether it's a bribe or not, I mean, maybe not, maybe it's kind of cast as a repayment or whatever, but definitely relations are, you know, have been couched in monetary terms, but they've also been couched in matrimonial terms. So Frederick's nephew has been engaged to Charles's sister. And although they never actually marry, the fact that they are kind of in-laws for this period, I mean, that also matters. And then of course, on top of that, there is the geopolitical context, which is that the Turks are at the gates and it's Charles's responsibility as emperor to construct a united front. And Saxony is very rich because of its silver mines.
你知道，查理感到欠他的人情。证据就是资金开始流入腓特烈的国库。我是说，这是否是贿赂并不重要，也许不是，也许它被视为一种偿还之类的，但毫无疑问，关系已经用金钱术语来表达了，但也用婚姻术语来表达了。所以腓特烈的侄子已经与查理的妹妹订婚了。虽然他们实际上从未结婚，但他们在这段时间里算是姻亲的事实，我是说，这也很重要。当然，除此之外，还有地缘政治背景，那就是土耳其人兵临城下，作为皇帝，查理有责任建立统一战线。而萨克森因为其银矿而非常富有。
And there is that reason as well, why Charles doesn't want to alienate Frederick. So just on Charles and the election, because I think it's nice to have a little bit of context, his main opponents in that election, so his rivals, everyone thinks he's probably going to get it because his grandfather Maximilian had been the emperor and it's kind of been a little bit of a Habsburg bauble
这也是查理不想疏远腓特烈的原因。关于查理和选举，因为我认为有一点背景信息很好，他在那次选举中的主要对手，也就是他的竞争对手——每个人都认为他可能会胜出，因为他的祖父马克西米利安曾是皇帝，这在过去几代人中一直有点像哈布斯堡家族的玩物，
for the last couple of generations. But his rivals are François I of France, but also our own Henry VIII, Tom. How different history might have been. Now, as you said, Charles wins a unanimous victory. Interestingly, though, we talked last time about kind of proto-nationalism. This is an age often thought of as being before nationalism, but national sentiments do exist.
但他的竞争对手是法国的弗朗索瓦一世，还有我们自己的亨利八世，汤姆。历史可能会有多么不同。现在，正如你所说，查理赢得了全票胜利。有趣的是，我们上次谈到了某种原始民族主义。这是一个常被认为在民族主义之前的时代，但民族情感确实存在。
Charles wins in the election, partly because he says, I'm the most German candidate. Well, he speaks German to his horse, doesn't he? Right. So Charles is a genuinely really, really interesting figure. He's not as well known in Britain or the English speaking world as he is in continental Europe, where he's a massive transcendent kind of historical figure. He's not as well known in Britain or the English speaking world as he is in continental Europe, where he's a massive, transcendent kind of historical figure. So he became, what is he? He's 20 when he meets Luther. Yeah. So he's born in 1500. Born in 1500 in Ghent, which is now in Belgium, which was then part of his kind of Netherlands possessions. He's the son of Philip theip the fair of burgundy and joanna the
查理在选举中获胜，部分原因是他声称：“我是最德国的候选人。”好吧，他对着他的马说德语，不是吗？对。所以查理是一个真正非常、非常有趣的人物。他在英国或英语世界不像在欧洲大陆那样出名，在那里他是一个巨大的、超凡脱俗的历史人物。他在英国或英语世界不像在欧洲大陆那样出名，在那里他是一个巨大的、超凡脱俗的历史人物。所以他成了……他是什么？他见路德时20岁。是的。所以他出生于1500年。出生于1500年的根特，现在属于比利时，当时是他荷兰领地的一部分。他是勃艮第的“美男子”菲利普和卡斯蒂利亚的“疯女”胡安娜的儿子，
mad of castile crazy name crazy girl yes very good he's incredibly well educated he speaks lots of different languages so the famous saying is he speaks spanish to god italian to women french to men and german to his horse yeah and he has an enormous jaw famously the hapsburg jaw and he has an enormous jaw, famously the Habsburg jaw, and he's intelligent and thoughtful, but he's also very introverted, gloomy, suspicious, cautious, and he's obviously only just come in as Holy Roman Emperor and he has this massive disparate role. I know, nightmare situation. He's facing the Ottomans yeah but also to maintain
疯狂的名字，疯狂的女孩，是的，非常好。他受过极好的教育，会说多种不同的语言，所以那句名言是：他对比上帝说西班牙语，对女人说意大利语，对男人说法语，对他的马说德语。是的，他有一个巨大的下巴，著名的哈布斯堡下巴，他有一个巨大的下巴，著名的哈布斯堡下巴，他聪明且深思熟虑，但他也非常内向、忧郁、多疑、谨慎，他显然才刚刚就任神圣罗马帝国皇帝，他肩负着这个巨大的、迥异的角色。我知道，噩梦般的处境。他面临着奥斯曼人，是的，但也要维持
unity as king of spain as ruler of the netherlands and burgundy yeah as ruler of this mad patchwork of the holy room that's a tough tough job and he can see that the schism between people who back luther and people who are loyal to the established church, I mean, is really threatening. And so he wants to somehow try and resolve that while also keeping Frederick on board. And so this is why he agrees that he will summon Luther to hear him at Worms. And so the summons arrives from Charles in Wittenberg on the 26th of March, and Luther is instructed to answer with regard to your books and teachings. And he is given three weeks to comply. And he also, Dominic, receives a personal
作为西班牙国王、荷兰和勃艮第统治者的统一，是的，作为这个神圣罗马帝国疯狂拼凑体的统治者，那是一项艰巨、艰巨的工作。他能看出支持路德的人与忠于既定教会的人之间的分裂，我是说，确实构成了威胁。所以他想以某种方式尝试解决这个问题，同时还要让腓特烈站在他这边。这就是为什么他同意召见路德在沃尔姆斯听取他的陈述。于是，查理的传票于3月26日送达维滕贝格，路德被指示“就你的书籍和教义”做出回答。他被给予三周时间来遵守。多米尼克，他还收到了皇帝个人的
assurance from the emperor of safe conduct. And listeners to earlier episodes will appreciate this may not be entirely reassuring to Luther because there is a salutary example of a professor accused of heresy being summoned by the imperial authorities to make a case and being given a safe conduct. And that is Jan Hus, who goes to Constance in 1414 and despite his safe conduct ends up being burnt. And that's the Bohemian reformer or would-be reformer who people saw as the sort of precursor to Luther. And Luther had said he'd been pushed into a corner by Johann Eck. And he had said, you know, I believe a lot of Hus' stuff. So that parallel must be hanging over him.
安全通行保证。早期剧集的听众会明白，这对路德来说可能并不完全令人放心，因为有一个因被指控异端而被帝国当局传唤进行辩护并获得安全通行证的教授的警示性例子。那就是1414年去康斯坦茨的扬·胡斯，尽管有安全通行证，他最终还是被烧死了。那是波希米亚的改革者或准改革者，人们视他为路德的前身。路德曾说他被约翰·埃克逼到了墙角。他说，你知道，我信仰胡斯的很多东西。所以那种相似之处一定一直笼罩着他。
Absolutely. And as he's going there, he says to a companion, we are all Hussites and did not realize it. So he's now overtly identifying himself with Huss. And he'd been a monk. He'd been a very devout Catholic. So he would have seen Huss as a heretic. He's in a monastery where one of the figures who condemns Huss is buried by the altar. But now, essentially, he's totally reversing his understanding of history. He's seeing Huss as the goody, and he's seeing the papacy as the baddy. And I think that he is going to Worms thinking that he might well be burnt. I mean, he cannot help but have this lesson from history weighing him down. And it's incredibly brave of him to do it. It's not a given that he will get
绝对是。当他去那里时，他对同伴说：“我们都是胡斯派，只是没意识到而已。”所以他现在公开地将自己与胡斯等同起来。他曾是一名僧侣。他曾是一名非常虔诚的天主教徒。所以他会把胡斯视为异端。他所在的修道院里，埋葬着一位谴责胡斯的人物，就在祭坛旁边。但现在，本质上，他正在彻底扭转他对历史的理解。他把胡斯视为好人，把教皇制度视为坏人。我认为他去沃尔姆斯时认为自己很可能会被烧死。我是说，他无法不让这个历史教训压在心头。他这样做是非常勇敢的。他能否脱身并不是板上钉钉的事。
away with this. So he leaves Wittenberg and he has his lawyer, who is the professor of law at Wittenberg, Hieronymus Scherf, who we've already mentioned. He's a guy who's always trying to slightly stop Luther from being quite as forthright as Luther tends to be. And they set out and they, obviously, they're very conspicuous on the road because Charles V has sent his herald, a guy called Kasper Sturm, and he leads this wagon with Luther and Scherf and various other people from Wittenberg. And the herald, he has the Imperial Eagle of Germany on his sleeves. And so every time they go on the road and they come into a town, huge excitement because Luther is, I mean, he's a massive, massive celebrity by this point. And great fun for Luther because he's going through places where he was educated.
所以他离开了维滕贝格，带着他的律师，也就是维滕贝格的法学教授希罗尼穆斯·谢尔夫，我们已经提到过他。他是一个总是试图稍微阻止路德像他倾向于做的那样直言不讳的人。他们出发了，显然，他们在路上非常显眼，因为查理五世派出了他的传令官，一个叫卡斯帕·斯图姆的人，他带领着这辆载着路德、谢尔夫和维滕贝格其他人的马车。传令官的袖子上印着德国的帝国鹰。所以每次他们上路进入一个城镇，都会引起巨大的轰动，因为路德此时已是一个巨大的、巨大的名人。这对路德来说很有趣，因为他经过的地方都是他受过教育的地方。
So he arrives in Erfurt where he'd been a student and huge party thrown for him. He gives a sermon and so many people crowd into the church that people are worried it's going to collapse. So it'd be like you, Dominic, turning up at Balliol and everyone holds a feast and they all come out to hear you. That probably would happen, Tom. I think that would happen. Do a live show of the rest of history or something. It would be great. But I think also, obviously, it's nerve wracking as well. So when he gets to Eisenbach, which is the Wartburg, that great castle, but it's where Luther had been at school,
所以他抵达了埃尔福特，他曾是那里的学生，那里为他举办了盛大的派对。他发表了一次布道，挤进教堂的人太多，以至于人们担心教堂会倒塌。所以这就像你，多米尼克，出现在贝利奥尔学院，每个人都为你举办宴会，他们都出来听你演讲。那可能会发生，汤姆。我想那会发生。做一场《历史就是如此》的现场秀之类的。那会很棒。但我认为，显然，这也让人神经紧张。所以当他到达艾森纳赫，也就是瓦尔特堡，那座伟大的城堡，但那是路德上学的地方，
he's so prostrated by panic attacks that he has to be bled. And Luther blames the devil for this. Luther is haunted by the sense that the devil is out to persecute him. Of course. But, you know, he's getting more and more nervous and he's just approaching firms when Frederick's secretary warns him not to enter the city because he is going to be condemned. So, very alarming.
他被恐慌发作折磨得瘫倒在地，不得不放血。路德把这归咎于魔鬼。路德一直被魔鬼要迫害他的感觉所困扰。当然。但是，你知道，他越来越紧张，就在他接近沃尔姆斯时，腓特烈的秘书警告他不要进入这座城市，因为他会被定罪。所以，非常令人担忧。
So it's a bit like Navalny going back to Russia, but making a stand. He's making a stand, but he knows it'll probably end in disaster. I think Luther is more hopeful that he may get away with it than Navalny.
所以这有点像纳瓦尔尼回到俄罗斯，但坚持立场。他坚持立场，但他知道这很可能以灾难告终。我认为路德比纳瓦尔尼更有希望脱身。
I think Navalny knew that he was doomed by going back. Luther doesn't think he's doomed, but of course, I mean, he has to be aware that death may be the result. But he kind of summons up his courage and he says, we shall enter in spite of the gates of hell and the powers of darkness. So he's doing what he always does, which is to cast himself as the agent of light and those who are opposing him as the agents of the devil. So we heard from the passage you read, the account by the papal legate that he arrives on the 16th of April. He's installed in very nice rooms near to the bishop's palace where his meeting with the emperor will take place. And he is summoned to meet Charles V the following afternoon, April the 17th. So just to paint a picture of Worms, Worms is on the western bank of the Rhine.
我认为纳瓦尔尼知道他回去就注定失败。路德不认为他注定失败，但当然，我是说，他必须意识到死亡可能是结果。但他鼓起勇气说：“即使地狱之门和黑暗势力阻挡，我们也要进入。”所以他做着他一贯做的事，那就是把自己塑造成光明的代理人，而那些反对他的人则是魔鬼的代理人。所以我们从你读的那段教皇使节的叙述中听到，他在4月16日抵达。他被安置在主教宫殿附近非常好的房间里，他与皇帝的会面将在那里举行。他被传唤在第二天下午，即4月17日会见查理五世。所以，为了描绘一下沃尔姆斯的景象，沃尔姆斯位于莱茵河西岸。
It's in the west of Germany. It's what's called an imperial free city. So it's self-governing under the emperor. There are stories that Luther is visited by representatives of the town's Jewish community because there's a big Jewish population in Worms. Right. And there are no Jews in Wittenberg. Right. So they have been expelled in the 14th century.
它在德国西部。它被称为帝国自由城市。所以它在皇帝治下实行自治。有传言说路德受到了该镇犹太社区代表的拜访，因为沃尔姆斯有大量的犹太人口。对。而维滕贝格没有犹太人。对。所以他们在14世纪就被驱逐了。
Also, its population has swelled to many times its normal size. I think there are something like 14,000 extra people there because the imperial diet, which is this regular assembly of the electors and other princes of the empire. Yeah. You know, these have been held since the 9th century when the empire was part of the Frankish kind of world. And you can imagine the streets full of hucksters, minstrels,
此外，它的人口膨胀到正常规模的许多倍。我想那里多了大约14,000人，因为帝国会议，也就是选侯和帝国其他诸侯的定期集会。是的。你知道，这些会议自9世纪帝国还是法兰克世界一部分时就开始举行了。你可以想象街道上挤满了小贩、吟游诗人、
tourists, you know, big crowds and great excitement. Yeah. So all the accounts of Luther's appearance here emphasize the crowds. So they say that when he goes to the meeting on the afternoon of the 17th of April, that the crowds are so great that he has to be taken in by a sideway. So he gets led through a garden and in through a side door to the meeting. And people are climbing onto the rooftops to see. And you talked about how in the introduction,
游客，你知道，拥挤的人群和巨大的兴奋。是的。所以所有关于路德在这里露面的叙述都强调了人群。所以他们说，当他在4月17日下午去参加会议时，人群如此之多，以至于他不得不从侧路被带进去。所以他被带过一个花园，从侧门进入会场。人们爬上屋顶观看。你在引言中谈到了，
the papal legate inadvertently is kind of conjuring up an image of Christ coming into Jerusalem. Luther's admirers are overtly saying that. They're overtly comparing these crowds to the crowds who come out to see Christ on Palm Sunday. Now, of course, that's not necessarily a reassurance. Yeah. Because Jesus still ends up being crucified.
教皇使节无意中唤起了一种基督进入耶路撒冷的形象。路德的崇拜者们公开地这样说。他们公开地将这些人群与棕枝主日出来看基督的人群进行比较。当然，这并不一定是一种安慰。是的。因为耶稣最终还是被钉在了十字架上。
And I think Luther is overwhelmed by it. I think he is really, really unsettled. So he walks into the chamber. The nobility of the empire are there. They're sumptuously arrayed in jewellery and robes and codpieces and everything. And Luther has just got his plain, simple cassock on. And even though lots of the nobles are shouting encouragement to him, it's a terrifying, overwhelming experience for him,
我认为路德被它淹没了。我认为他真的、真的很不安。所以他走进会场。帝国的贵族们都在那里。他们穿着华丽的珠宝、长袍、遮羞布等等。而路德只穿着他那件朴素、简单的法衣。即使许多贵族对他大声鼓励，对他来说，这仍然是一种可怕的、压倒性的体验，
particularly because there at the end of the room, of course, is the emperor himself. And there is also a table that has a great pile of all his various publications. That's your nightmare, isn't it? You're called into a meeting of the biggest people in the world. Yeah, it is, isn't it? That you're called into a meeting of the biggest people in the world. Yeah, it is, isn't it? And there are all your books. They have to be dissected. Yeah.
特别是房间尽头当然就是皇帝本人。还有一张桌子，上面堆着他各种各样的出版物。那是你的噩梦，不是吗？你被叫去参加一个世界上最重要人物的会议。是的，是这样，不是吗？你被叫去参加一个世界上最重要人物的会议。是的，是这样，不是吗？那里有你所有的书。它们必须被剖析。是的。
Yeah. And they cut, you know, looking at them disapprovingly and say, have you written them? And this is asked both first in Latin and then in German. And Scherf, Luther's lawyer, says, let the titles of the books be read. So, Dominic, Seasons in the Sun. I'd love that. All that.
是的。他们切开，你知道，不赞同地看着它们说：“是你写的吗？”这个问题先用拉丁语问，然后用德语问。谢尔夫，路德的律师说：“请读出书名。”所以，多米尼克，《阳光下的季节》。我很喜欢那个。所有这些。
I'd actually love that, Tom. And the whole way through, Luther is supposed to only answer yes or no. So this interrogation has been structured so that he won't have an opportunity to grandstand because everyone is aware, his enemies, that he's very, very good at this. So the whole thing has been structured to ensure that he can't start freewheeling. And I think he's very upset by this and intimidated. So he adopts a delaying strategy. He's asked, will you recant and revoke your books? And he says to this, I don't know. I want to have time to think about it. And he says, this is the question of faith and the salvation of souls. And because it concerns the divine word, which we are all bound to reverence, for there is
汤姆，我其实很喜欢那个。整个过程中，路德应该只回答“是”或“否”。所以这次审讯的结构是为了让他没有机会作秀，因为每个人——他的敌人们——都知道他非常、非常擅长这个。所以整个事情的结构是为了确保他不能开始信口开河。我认为他对此感到非常不安和胆怯。所以他采取了拖延策略。他被问到：“你愿意撤回并废除你的书吗？”他对此回答：“我不知道。我想有时间考虑一下。”他说：“这是信仰和灵魂救赎的问题。因为它涉及神圣的道，我们都有义务去敬畏，因为在天上或地上没有
nothing greater in heaven or on earth. And so he asked for an adjournment and this is granted. But Tom, this is unbelievable. He's gone all this way and there are huge crowds. And then he goes into this room. You know, it's like something from the Lord of the Rings or Star Wars or something. People in their magnificent robes and just this one lone monk. And then he gets in and says, I'll come back tomorrow.
比这更伟大的东西。”所以他要求休会，这被批准了。但汤姆，这令人难以置信。他走了这么远，有巨大的人群。然后他走进这个房间。你知道，这就像《指环王》或《星球大战》之类的东西。人们穿着华丽的长袍，只有这一个孤独的僧侣。然后他进去说：“我明天再来。”
But it is a genius tactic. It's theater, right? It's absolute theater. He is brilliant at this PR. What chutzpah to say that to the emperor and to all of these electors and princes and counts and whatever they are. What extraordinary confidence. But also, Dominic, it's a kind of silence before the imperial power. And who else was silent before the imperial power?
但这是一种天才的策略。这是戏剧，对吧？这是绝对的戏剧。他在公关方面非常出色。对皇帝和所有这些选侯、诸侯、伯爵以及他们是什么人说那样的话，需要多大的胆量啊。多么非凡的自信。但多米尼克，这也是一种在帝国权力面前的沉默。还有谁在帝国权力面前保持沉默？
When he goes out from the hall for his adjournment, the crowds out there are calling on him to be strong, to be brave, not to give in. And there are lots of them who are openly comparing him to Christ before Pilate. I think he's consciously making play with this, even as he is also playing for time. We've talked about this again and again and again. Luther's genius for the dramatic moment that people will remember and talk about and mythologize. And on that thing of comparing himself to Jesus, or at least role-playing as Jesus, as it were, this is somebody who not long ago was having six-hour therapy sessions with his confessor because he felt unworthy.
当他走出大厅休会时，外面的人群呼吁他要坚强，要勇敢，不要屈服。他们中有许多人公开地将他与彼拉多面前的基督进行比较。我认为他是有意识地在利用这一点，即使他也在争取时间。我们一次又一次地谈论过这一点。路德对人们会记住、谈论和神话化的戏剧性时刻的天才。关于他将自己与耶稣进行比较，或者至少扮演耶稣的角色，这是一个不久前还因为感到不配而与他的忏悔神父进行六小时治疗的人。
Does he now just feel kind of puffed up as maybe too harsh? No, the Lord is with him. He's born again. God loves him. Yeah, he's invigorated. He's loving this. And he does think reenacting the journey of Jesus, as it were, he thinks it's fine because I'm doing the Lord's work. Christ is with him. Christ is in his heart. That is his state of grace. Right. Okay. So he
他现在只是感到有点膨胀，也许太苛刻了？不，主与他同在。他重生了。上帝爱他。是的，他精力充沛。他喜欢这样。他确实认为重演耶稣的旅程，正如他所做的那样，他认为这很好，因为我在做主的工作。基督与他同在。基督在他心中。那是他的恩典状态。对。好的。所以他
goes back the following afternoon. So that's now we're now on the 18th of April. And so many people want to see this showdown that they've had to move it to a bigger hall. And even as it is, some of the princes who've come, they have to stand. So this is the measure of how this is by miles, the hottest ticket in town. And Luther goes in and by now it's getting dark. The torches are burning, the shadows are flickering. And he is asked the same question, will you recant and revote your books? And Luther replies, rather as he had done to Khadhatan, the cardinal who we talked about in the previous episode, that he will, if it can be shown from scripture, that they contain errors. But otherwise he won't.
第二天下午又回去了。所以现在是4月18日。太多人想看这场决战，他们不得不把它搬到一个更大的大厅。即便如此，一些前来的诸侯也不得不站着。所以这就是它为何是城里最热门门票的衡量标准。路德进去了，此时天色渐暗。火把在燃烧，阴影在闪烁。他被问到同样的问题：“你愿意撤回并废除你的书吗？”路德回答，就像他之前对我们在上一集中谈到的红衣主教卡耶坦所做的那样，如果能从圣经中证明它们包含错误，他就会撤回。但否则他不会。
And he says, you know, these books, the things I have to say, look at the stir they have created here in the city, across the empire. And I'm not going to apologize for this because basically the excitement that my books have created is proving the truth of what they say. And he says to see excitement and dissension arise because of the word of God is to me clearly the most joyful aspect of all in these matters. So he's turning on its head the charge of his enemies that he is creating public unrest and saying, well, yes, the public unrest is the proof of the value of what I'm doing. For this is the way, the opportunity and the result of the word of God, just as Christ said, I have not come to bring peace, but a sword. And whenever a Christian leader starts
他说：“你知道，这些书，我要说的话，看看它们在这里、在整个帝国引起了多大的骚动。我不会为此道歉，因为基本上，我的书引起的兴奋证明了它们所说的是真理。”他说：“看到因为上帝的道而引起兴奋和分歧，对我来说显然是这些事情中最令人高兴的方面。”所以他颠倒了敌人们对他制造公共动乱的指控，并说：“好吧，是的，公共动乱证明了我所做之事的价值。因为这就是上帝之道的方式、机会和结果，正如基督所说：‘我来不是为了带来和平，而是为了带来一把剑。’”每当一位基督教领袖开始
saying that, it was slightly nerve wracking. But the thing with the inquisitor, sorry, the inquisitor says to him, Tom, doesn't he? Luther says, you know, basically to make me recant, you'd have to prove in the Bible. I mean, it's just the Bible or nothing for me. Yeah. But even at this point, the inquisitor, who's a guy slightly confusingly, he's called Johan X. So he has the same name as a previous Johan X. We had waves of X. But he's a different man.
说那样的话，就有点让人神经紧张。但关于审判官的事情，抱歉，审判官对他说，汤姆，不是吗？路德说，你知道，基本上要让我撤回，你必须在圣经中证明。我是说，对我来说，要么是圣经，要么什么都不是。是的。但即使在这一点上，审判官——一个有点令人困惑的人，他叫约翰·埃克。所以他和之前的约翰·埃克同名。我们有几波埃克。但他是一个不同的人。
And Johan X says, you know, all heretics go on about the Bible. I mean, he makes this point. He says, you're talking about scripture, but that's what all heretics do. That's why you need the church as the institution to explain what the Bible means, because otherwise it's too ambiguous and it's too unclear. And that issue, that conflict between the two, I mean, that runs through hundreds of years of not just Protestant versus Catholic, but kind of Western civilization, the individual conscience versus the institution. Yeah, absolutely. Because Luther is taking for granted that the Spirit is speaking through him, that his understanding of the Word is self-evidently the truth, and that if everyone
约翰·埃克说：“你知道，所有的异端都谈论圣经。我是说，他指出了这一点。他说，你在谈论圣经，但那是所有异端都会做的事。这就是为什么你需要教会作为机构来解释圣经的意思，因为否则它太模棱两可，太不清楚了。”而那个问题，两者之间的冲突，我是说，那贯穿了数百年的不仅是新教与天主教的冲突，还有某种西方文明的冲突，个人良知与机构的冲突。是的，绝对是。因为路德认为圣灵正在通过他说话，他对比圣经的理解自明地就是真理，如果每个人
shares in his experience, they will understand the Word of God exactly as he does. And that is his position. And this is what gives him the strength to face down the Inquisitor. And when the Inquisitor accuses him of basically playing scholastic games, playing the kind of the university lecturer, trying to wriggle out of situations with fine sounding sophistry, Luther makes this ringing statement. around him, he says that he scorns all the pretensions of popes and councils and inquisitors because he is bound only by the understanding of scripture that has been revealed to him by the spirit. And he says, my conscience is captive to the word of God. So that word conscience again, which he keeps emphasizing, I cannot, and I will not retract anything since it is neither safe nor right to go against conscience. And according to the transcript of the interrogation, this is where he stops. This is his final statement. But according to the transcript that in due course
分享他的体验，他们就会像他一样理解上帝的道。这就是他的立场。这就是让他有力量面对审判官的原因。当审判官指责他基本上是在玩经院哲学游戏，玩那种大学讲师试图用听起来高明的诡辩来摆脱困境的游戏时，路德发表了这一响亮的声明。在他周围，他说他蔑视教皇、议会和审判官的所有虚张声势，因为他只受圣灵向他揭示的圣经理解的约束。他说：“我的良心被上帝的道所俘虏。”所以那个“良心”这个词再次出现，他不断强调，“我不能，我也不会撤回任何东西，因为违背良心既不安全也不正确。”根据审讯记录，这就是他停止的地方。这是他的最后陈述。但根据随后
will be released by his supporters in Wittenberg, he then goes on to utter a ringing phrase that will probably be the most famous thing he ever says. I cannot do otherwise. Here I stand. Here stay ich. And this phrase will ring across the empire and indeed, Dominic, down the centuries. And so basically his enemies have handed Luther exactly what they didn't want to do, which is a chance to make his case in front of the emperor himself. The simple monk opposed by all the panoply and power of the emperor of the church. And it's an amazing moment. Tom, that moment, by the way, that phrase, here I stand, I can do no other, or however you translate it, Dietmar McCulloch in his book on the Reformation says that's the motto, not just of the Reformation, but of all modern Western
由他在维滕贝格的支持者发布的记录，他接着说出了一句响亮的短语，这可能是他所说过的最著名的话。“我不能做别的。我站在这里。”（Here I stand. Hier stehe ich.）这句话将在整个帝国回荡，确实，多米尼克，跨越几个世纪。所以基本上，他的敌人们给了路德他们最不想给的东西，那就是一个在皇帝本人面前陈述他观点的机会。被教会皇帝的所有盛装和权力所反对的简单僧侣。这是一个了不起的时刻。汤姆，顺便说一句，那个短语，“我站在这里，我不能做别的”，或者无论你怎么翻译它，迪特马尔·麦卡洛克在他的宗教改革书中说，那是不仅是宗教改革的座右铭，也是所有现代西方
civilization. Yeah. Living my truth. Yeah. That's what it is, right? Exactly. Yeah. And that's why it reverberates. That's why it has the influence it does. And it means that Luther, rather than the emperor, is center stage in the way that people understand this confrontation. But two days after he's heard Luther make the statement, Charles V writes his reply. And he says that he is staying true to the example set by his predecessors as emperor. He will always be a defender of the Catholic faith, of its rituals and its decrees and
文明的座右铭。是的。活出我的真理。是的。这就是它，对吧？完全正确。是的。这就是它产生回响的原因。这就是它产生影响的原因。这意味着路德，而不是皇帝，在人们理解这场对抗的方式中处于中心舞台。但在他听到路德发表声明两天后，查理五世写了他的回复。他说他坚持他作为皇帝的前任们所树立的榜样。他将永远是天主教信仰、其仪式、其法令、其
its ordinances and its customs and so on. And so he confirms Luther's excommunication. Nevertheless, he is a man of his word. He had given Luther safe passage, he is a man of his word. He had given Luther safe passage. And so he will hold to that. But Luther has three weeks. And after that, he will be arrested and liquidated.
条例和习俗等的捍卫者。所以他确认了路德的绝罚。尽管如此，他是一个信守诺言的人。他给了路德安全通行证，他是一个信守诺言的人。他给了路德安全通行证。所以他会坚持这一点。但路德有三周时间。在那之后，他将被逮捕并清算。
And that is the word that he used. Right. I think that's fair, Tom. I think that reflects well on Charles V. And the Diet carries on. And on the 26th of May, so this is the day after the diet ends of sweeps like wildfire by luther's supporters saying that the inquisitors in worms had gathered up all luther's books and burnt them but on the top there was an image of luther and that this didn't burn oh that definitely happened that definitely happened and you'll remember in the passage you read the papal legate saying people
这就是他使用的词。对。我认为这很公平，汤姆。我认为这反映了查理五世的良好品格。帝国会议继续进行。在5月26日，也就是会议结束后的第二天，路德的支持者们像野火一样传开说，沃尔姆斯的审判官收集了路德所有的书并烧毁了它们，但在上面有一张路德的画像，而且这没有烧掉。哦，那肯定发生了，那肯定发生了，你会记得你读的那段教皇使节说人们
will be calling him a saint soon i mean the paradox is that all this kind of miraculous stuff of, you know, images not burning. I mean, this is very pre-Reformation, one might say. Yeah. But also, Dominic, just to say, and to reiterate a point that you made earlier about how really the question is, how does Luther know that what he's saying is right? Because what Charles V says in his response is that he doesn't pretend to deep theological knowledge. He's not a professor of theology and
很快就会称他为圣人，我是说，悖论在于所有这些关于画像没有烧掉的奇迹般的事情。我是说，这非常前宗教改革，人们可能会说。是的。但多米尼克，只是想说，并重申你之前提出的关于问题实际上是“路德怎么知道他所说的是对的？”的观点。因为查理五世在他的回应中所说的是，他不假装有深厚的神学知识。他不是神学教授，
the Bible as Luther is, but he doesn't understand how a single monk could be correct in an opinion, which, as Charles puts it, according to which all of Christianity will be and will always have been in error, both in the past thousand years and even more in the present. I mean, that's such a fair point, right? Because Charles V could reasonably say, listen, fellow, Christianity is what the Christian church says it is. End of story. Yeah, right. So if the whole Christian church says, this is Christianity, and you say, no, it isn't, it's something else, you're by definition wrong because the church decides. Yeah. And Dominic, what's interesting is that there is a humanist scholar called Johann Cocleus who is in Worms and he's come sympathetic to Luther. And he's
也不是像路德那样的圣经学者，但他不明白一个单一的僧侣怎么可能在一个观点上是正确的，正如查理所说，根据这个观点，整个基督教在过去一千年甚至现在都将一直处于错误之中。我是说，这是一个非常公平的观点，对吧？因为查理五世可以合理地说：“听着，伙计，基督教就是基督教会所说的那个样子。故事结束。”是的，对。所以如果整个基督教会说：“这就是基督教”，而你说：“不，不是，它是别的东西”，你按定义就是错的，因为教会决定。是的。多米尼克，有趣的是，有一位名叫约翰·科克莱乌斯的人文主义学者在沃尔姆斯，他来的时候是同情路德的。他
worrying about this. He wants to know kind of what Luther thinks. So on the 24th of April, while Luther is still in Worms, He gets himself invited to dinner in Luther's rooms and he finds himself sitting between Luther and Frederick the Wise, the elector who's there as well. And he presses Luther on this point and Luther doesn't really give him convincing answers. And so Luther, after dinner, goes back to his quarters and Cocleus follows him. So it's exactly the kind of behaviour that you really don't want. It's exactly how I expect theologians to behave to be fair. But Luther allows Cucleus in. Cucleus pulls back his cloak and shows that he doesn't have a sword
担心这一点。他想知道路德是怎么想的。所以4月24日，当路德还在沃尔姆斯时，他让自己被邀请到路德的房间吃晚饭，他发现自己坐在路德和腓特烈选侯之间，后者也在那里。他向路德施压这一点，路德并没有真正给他令人信服的答案。所以路德晚饭后回到他的住处，科克莱乌斯跟着他。所以这正是你真的不希望发生的那种行为。这正是神学家们行为的方式，说实话。但路德让科克莱乌斯进去了。科克莱乌斯拉开他的斗篷，显示他没有带剑
or anything. And Cucleus keeps pressing him and saying, how do you know that your interpretation of scripture is right? Surely everyone will have different interpretations. And Luther's answer is that the meaning of God's word is plain. If the spirit illum you then you will you will know you'll get it right tom i'm sorry this is such obvious tosh okay well kakleas is with you he agrees and the argument between them becomes so intense that the two of them fall out irrevocably and kakleas from being an admirer of luther becomes one of his most inveterate enemies and the accounts that that he will write of Luther are so abusive and so popular with Luther's enemies that they will influence how Catholics see Luther for centuries and centuries to come. But I agree, he has kind of zoomed in on what, as events will show, is the big issue for Luther and indeed for the entire Reformation. And really, in a way,
或任何东西。科克莱乌斯不断地逼问他，说：“你怎么知道你对圣经的解释是正确的？肯定每个人都会有不同的解释。”路德的回答是，上帝之道的意思是显而易见的。如果圣灵启示你，那么你就会知道，你会做对的。汤姆，我很抱歉，这简直是显而易见的胡言乱语。好吧，科克莱乌斯和你站在一起，他同意，他们之间的争论变得如此激烈，以至于两人不可挽回地闹翻了，科克莱乌斯从路德的崇拜者变成了他最根深蒂固的敌人之一，他所写的关于路德的叙述是如此辱骂，并且在路德的敌人中如此受欢迎，以至于它们将影响几个世纪以来天主教徒看待路德的方式。但我同意，他确实聚焦于——正如事件将表明的那样——路德乃至整个宗教改革的大问题。而且真的，在某种程度上，
this is the high point of the identification of Luther with a single Reformation. Up until this point, he has been like Elvis or someone. He is the dominant figure. I can't believe you're compared with Elvis. Right. So Elvis is the king. He dominates the world of rock and roll. And then, of course, he gets drafted and he vanishes from the scene. And something rather similar to that happens to Luther because he has this three-week period of grace before the agents of the emperor will arrest him. He's heading back to Wittenberg and he's leaving Worms. He's a hero and he's an outlaw, even more famous than he had been before the diet.
这是路德与单一宗教改革运动挂钩的最高点。在此之前，他就像猫王或类似的人物。他是占据主导地位的人物。真不敢相信你竟然拿他跟猫王比。没错。猫王是摇滚之王，他统治了摇滚乐的世界。然后，当然，他被征召入伍，从舞台上消失了。路德身上也发生了类似的事情，因为在皇帝的代理人逮捕他之前，他有三周的宽限期。他正从沃尔姆斯返回维滕贝格。他既是英雄，也是逃犯，比帝国会议之前更加出名。
The star of countless pamphlets, spreading news of his great confrontation with the emperor across the whole of the German speaking world and beyond. And then comes this extraordinary twist. He's halfway back to Wittenberg, going through Thuringia, through a ravine, when suddenly he gets ambushed. A posse of horsemen confront him. They've got crossbows. They point them at Luther and his companions, and they abduct Luther and two of the people who are traveling with Luther, put them onto their horses, gallop away. The hoofbeats fade, nothing left but dust. And there is no clue as to who has taken Luther, where he has gone, what his fate is. And it is the case that the most famous man in Europe has vanished from the face of the earth.
他是无数小册子的主角，将他与皇帝的伟大对抗的消息传遍了整个德语世界乃至更远的地方。然后出现了这个非同寻常的转折。他在返回维滕贝格的半路上，穿过图林根，经过一个峡谷时，突然遭到伏击。一队骑兵拦住了他。他们拿着弩，指着路德和他的同伴，绑架了路德和与他同行的两个人，把他们拉上马，飞驰而去。马蹄声渐行渐远，只剩下尘土。没有人知道是谁带走了路德，他去了哪里，命运如何。欧洲最著名的人就这样从地球上消失了。
What an unbelievable cliffhanger, Tom. Such exciting scenes. But the good news for the listeners is they just need to return after the break and they'll find out what has happened to Martin Luther. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
真是令人难以置信的悬念，汤姆。场面太刺激了。但对听众来说好消息是，你们只需要在休息后回来，就能知道马丁·路德发生了什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We ended the first half with an extraordinary cliffhanger. Tom, men with crossbows, riding off into the dust with Luther, kidnapped.
在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《其余皆历史》。我们在上半场结束时留下了一个非同寻常的悬念。汤姆，拿着弩的人骑马带着路德消失在尘土中，他被绑架了。
Who has taken him and why? Well, Dominic, he's been abducted by agents of Frederick the Wise, the Elector of Saxony, and they have taken him to a place that Luther knows very well. It's Eisenach, where he had been to school, and specifically to the Wartburg, the great castle that broods over the town. And he's taken there and he gets disguised as a knight. So he takes off his cassock. He even gets to wear a codpiece. an amazing transformation he grows his hair out so the tonsil goes grows a beard and he looks like a like a knight so he's called yunca georg yunca george knight george by his keepers and he he doesn't make a very convincing night he occasionally gets taken out hunting and he falls off his horse and he sobs over the hair there's occasion where he
是谁带走了他，为什么？嗯，多米尼克，他是被萨克森选帝侯“智者”腓特烈的代理人绑架的，他们把他带到了一个路德非常熟悉的地方。那是艾森纳赫，他曾在那儿上过学，具体来说是瓦尔特堡，那座俯瞰全城的宏伟城堡。他被带到那里，伪装成一名骑士。他脱掉了法衣，甚至穿上了遮羞布。这真是一次惊人的转变，他留长了头发，所以头顶的剃发圈不见了，还留起了胡子，看起来就像个骑士。所以他的看守们叫他“乔治骑士”。他扮演的骑士并不怎么令人信服，他偶尔会被带出去打猎，结果从马上摔下来，还对着野兔啜泣。有一次他
picks up a hair and shelters it in his cloak and the dogs just reek up and kind of grab the hair and chew it to pieces. But he is allowed out. He's not just locked up completely. He is allowed out, but under very close supervision. Most of the time he's kept in the castle because obviously Frederick doesn't want the emperor to know that he is responsible for looking after a condemned heretic. So most of the time Luther is stuck in his room, which is very small, has a high ceiling, very plain furniture. And he's plunged into kind of gloomy introspection.
捡起一只野兔，把它藏在斗篷里，结果狗冲上来，把野兔撕成了碎片。但他被允许外出。他并没有被完全关起来。他可以在严密监视下外出。大部分时间他都被关在城堡里，因为显然腓特烈不想让皇帝知道他负责看管一名被定罪的异端分子。所以大部分时间路德都被困在房间里，房间很小，天花板很高，家具非常简陋。他陷入了一种阴郁的内省之中。
And we know... He loves that. You know, from his time as a monk, that he's a great man for gloominess. He needs a bit of better help, Dominic. Yeah, he does. That's really what he needs. He totally does. And so, as is always the case when he's unhappy,
我们知道……他喜欢这样。你知道，从他做修士的时期起，他就是一个非常忧郁的人。他需要一点更好的帮助，多米尼克。是的，他确实需要。那才是他真正需要的。他完全需要。所以，正如他心情不好时一贯的那样，
what does he start obsessing about? Oh, Tom, amaze me. He starts obsessing about his bowels. Right. And so he does write letters to close friends and all he does is moan on about his constipation, saying I'm constipated for days on an end. And he has this very vivid description of how agonizing it is finally to get released that I'm sure all mothers listening to this will really enjoy. He says, now I sit in agony like a woman in childbirth, ripped up and bloody. God, that's pretty intense constipation, isn't it? Yeah. And he sees this obviously as being persecution by the devil.
他开始沉迷于什么？哦，汤姆，让我大吃一惊吧。他开始沉迷于自己的肠道问题。没错。他给亲密朋友写信，整天抱怨便秘，说他连续几天便秘。他对自己最终排便时的痛苦有非常生动的描述，我相信所有听这个节目的母亲都会深有感触。他说，现在我像个分娩的女人一样痛苦地坐着，被撕裂且血淋淋的。天哪，那便秘够严重的，不是吗？是的。他显然认为这是魔鬼对他的迫害。
And so he writes it almost every night when I wake up there he is itching to argue with me and this is the period that generates the famous story of Luther throwing an ink well an ink pot yeah at the devil and supposedly the ink is is available to be seen in the fuck book this is not true okay I mean certainly the devil wasn't there but he didn't throw an ink pot at it but there are other stories that Luther does substantiate later in life. And there is a story that the devil comes into his room disguised as a dog and Luther picks the dog up and hurls it out of the window. So Tom, I was really struck by this. This is the one thing that most interests me about Arthur and Luther because we have talked about other dog murderers and the rest is history.
所以他几乎每天晚上醒来时都会写道，魔鬼就在那里，急于与我争论。这段时期产生了路德向魔鬼投掷墨水瓶的著名故事。没错，墨水瓶。据说墨水痕迹在瓦尔特堡还能看到。这不是真的，好吧。我的意思是，魔鬼肯定不在那里，他也没有向魔鬼扔墨水瓶，但路德在晚年确实证实了其他故事。有一个故事说魔鬼伪装成一只狗进入他的房间，路德抱起那只狗把它扔出了窗外。所以汤姆，我对此印象非常深刻。这是关于亚瑟和路德最让我感兴趣的一点，因为我们在《其余皆历史》中谈论过其他杀狗凶手。
Jeremy Thorpe, Tom, the cad bounder and erstwhile leader of the Liberal Party. Friend of the show, though, I think. Very much a friend of the show. And Jaco Macaco. Another friend of the show. The fighting monkey who defeated a dog at the Westminster pit. And actually, there are some interesting parallels there. So Jaco Macaco, as with Martin Luther, there's a lot of mystery. We don't know what kind of monkey he was. And with Luther, some of his spiritual crisis is obscure to us, isn't it? And Martin Luther, you talked very powerfully about him and technology and his use of pioneering
杰里米·索普，汤姆，那个无赖、混蛋，曾经的自由党领袖。不过我想他是节目的朋友。非常是节目的朋友。还有雅科·马卡科。节目的另一位朋友。那只在威斯敏斯特斗兽场打败了狗的战斗猴子。实际上，这里有一些有趣的相似之处。所以雅科·马卡科和马丁·路德一样，有很多谜团。我们不知道他是什么品种的猴子。而对于路德，他的一些精神危机对我们来说也是模糊的，不是吗？马丁·路德，你非常有力地谈到了他与技术以及他对开创性技术的运用。
technology. And of course, Jeremy Thorpe was a great enthusiast for the hovercraft. For the hovercraft. Yes, the parallels are piling up. But Dominic, I would say one way in which certainly he's not similar to Jaco Macaco is that Luther is a great dog lover. And I think that this is actually what makes this story terribly sad. Really? Especially for the dog?
当然，杰里米·索普是气垫船的狂热爱好者。为了气垫船。是的，相似之处越来越多。但多米尼克，我想说，他与雅科·马卡科绝对不相似的一点是，路德是一个伟大的爱狗人士。我认为这正是让这个故事变得极其悲伤的原因。真的吗？特别是对那只狗而言？
Yeah, but also for Luther. I mean, at least, you know, the dog is blah, blah, and then it's all over. But for Luther, the agony continues because he adores dogs. Oh, he's the real victim, is he? He's the real victim. So he says about dogs that, Our Lord God has made the best gifts the most common, which I think is adorable. And there's a very sweet thing that he sees a dog wagging its tail, and he says,
是的，但对路德也是。我的意思是，至少，你知道，那只狗是“吧啦吧啦”，然后一切就结束了。但对路德来说，痛苦还在继续，因为他非常喜爱狗。哦，他是真正的受害者，是吗？他是真正的受害者。所以他谈到狗时说，我们的上帝创造了最美好的礼物，却让它们变得最普通，我觉得这很可爱。还有一件非常甜蜜的事，他看到一只狗摇着尾巴，他说，
Be thou comforted, little dog. Thou too, in resurrection, shall have a little golden tail. That's guilt talking. That is guilt talking, Tom. No, it's not. No, it's not. He wouldn't say that. He wasn't a notorious Rinker-style dog murderer.
“小狗啊，你得安慰。在复活之时，你也会有一条金色的小尾巴。”那是内疚在说话。那是内疚在说话，汤姆。不，不是。不，不是。他不会那样说的。他不是一个臭名昭著的林克式杀狗凶手。
Oh, that I could only pray the way that my puppy stares at meat. No one who didn't love dogs would come out with that. Rubbish. That's sinister. Well, anyway, Dominic, it's the fault of the devil. It's not Luther's fault. It's the devil persecuting him. That's what Jeremy Thorpe said in court to Mr. Justice Cantley. No.
“哦，我真希望我能像我的小狗盯着肉那样祈祷。”没有爱狗的人是不会说出这种话的。胡说八道。那太阴险了。好吧，无论如何，多米尼克，这是魔鬼的错。这不是路德的错。是魔鬼在迫害他。这就是杰里米·索普在法庭上对坎特利法官说的话。不。
Also, Luther is the person who seems to have coined the word poltergeist. So an invisible ghost that throws things around. Really? Luther coins the word? Yes, I think so. Wow. That's what Roger Clark writes in his brilliant book, A Natural History of Ghosts. And I have no reason to doubt him. Yeah. But Luther coins the word because he doesn't actually believe in ghosts because ghosts supposedly come from purgatory. Luther doesn supposedly come from purgatory. Luther doesn't believe in purgatory. So actually, this poltergeist who's chucking nuts at him is clearly the devil again.
此外，路德似乎是创造“骚灵”（poltergeist）这个词的人。也就是一个会到处扔东西的隐形鬼魂。真的吗？路德创造了这个词？是的，我想是这样。哇。这是罗杰·克拉克在他那本精彩的《鬼魂自然史》中写的。我没有理由怀疑他。是的。但路德创造这个词是因为他实际上并不相信鬼魂，因为鬼魂据说来自炼狱。路德不相信炼狱。所以实际上，这个向他扔坚果的骚灵显然又是魔鬼。
The poltergeist is throwing nuts at him. He's killing dogs and people are throwing nuts at him. Come on. Well, he's coming in disguised as a dog and he's throwing nuts. So it's not surprising that Luther is very unsettled by this. Yeah, he's a troubled man, I think it's fair to say. But he says he has a fail-safe method for getting rid of the devil
骚灵在向他扔坚果。他在杀狗，而人们在向他扔坚果。得了吧。好吧，他是伪装成狗进来的，而且他在扔坚果。所以路德对此感到非常不安也就不足为奇了。是的，我认为公平地说，他是一个陷入困境的人。但他确实说他有一种万无一失的方法来驱赶魔鬼，
when prayer fails to get rid of the devil. And I quote Luther, I chase him away with a fart. Yeah. So the constipation isn't all bad. There's stuff going on in his mind, Tom, that we can't even begin to imagine. I mean, just to reiterate,
当祈祷无法驱赶魔鬼时。我引用路德的话：“我用一个屁把他赶走。”是的。所以便秘也不全是坏事。汤姆，他的脑子里发生了一些我们甚至无法想象的事情。我的意思是，重申一下，
I mean, all this is kind of knockabout stuff, but the devil is intensely real for Luther. Yeah. And he is wrestling with the devil very profoundly. And ultimately his solution to this crisis, the fact that the devil is coming in as a dog and throwing nuts at him and all kinds of things, is the one that I think that we would all do in his situation, which is to translate the New Testament. Of course, that's the first thing I thought of. Wouldn't you do that? Yes, absolutely. If you can't get better help, translate the New Testament.
我的意思是，所有这些都是些胡闹的东西，但魔鬼对路德来说是极其真实的。是的。他正在非常深刻地与魔鬼搏斗。最终，他解决这场危机的方案——即魔鬼化身为狗向他扔坚果等等——是我认为我们在他的处境下都会做的事情，那就是翻译《新约》。当然，这是我首先想到的。你难道不会那样做吗？是的，绝对会。如果得不到更好的帮助，就翻译《新约》。
And it's not the first time that the New Testament has been translated into German. Since Gutenberg appeared on the scene, a German translation has been printed and has actually been reprinted 13 times. So it's definitely out there. But Luther is the first to translate it directly from Greek rather than from Latin, so from the original language. And it takes him 11 weeks and it is massively influential. I'm not in any way, not actually speaking German, really qualified to say this, but I gather that it has a heft in German similar to the King James Bible
而且这并不是《新约》第一次被翻译成德语。自从古腾堡出现以来，德语译本就已经被印刷出来，并且实际上已经重印了13次。所以它肯定已经存在了。但路德是第一个直接从希腊语而不是从拉丁语翻译的人，也就是从原始语言翻译。这花了他11周的时间，而且影响巨大。我并没有真正说德语，所以没有资格说这个，但我认为它在德语中的分量类似于英语中的《钦定版圣经》。
in English. Oh, it's massive. But whereas the King James Bible is all very sonorous, it may not surprise listeners at this point to learn that apparently Luther's translation is much earthier. It is earthy. I looked it up, Tom. And Luther writes in very short, unusually for somebody writing in German. He writes very short sentences and using the shortest possible words. And designed to be accessible, right? Yeah. The very famous things that he wrote later on a hymn, Ein fester Burg ist ein Gott, a strong fortress is that God. And the very, very short words and very kind of easily comprehensible.
哦，它非常重要。但《钦定版圣经》听起来非常宏亮，此时听众可能不会感到惊讶，路德的译本显然要朴实得多。它确实很朴实。我查过了，汤姆。路德写的句子非常短，这对于用德语写作的人来说很不寻常。他写的是非常短的句子，并使用尽可能短的词汇。旨在让大众能够理解，对吧？是的。他后来写的一首非常著名的赞美诗《上帝是我们的坚固堡垒》（Ein feste Burg ist unser Gott）。词汇非常非常短，而且非常容易理解。
That's Luther's populism again, isn't it? Yeah. You can see why he became an important figure for kind of German nationalists, because he invents German, the language, to some degree, as Chaucer does with English. The vernacular. Yes. He shapes the vernacular. Yeah. And you see, I think one of the really, really underappreciated things about Luther, which
那又是路德的民粹主义，不是吗？是的。你可以看出为什么他成为了德国民族主义者的重要人物，因为他在某种程度上发明了德语，就像乔叟对英语所做的那样。方言。是的。他塑造了方言。是的。我认为关于路德，一个真正被低估的事情是，
you've brought out really brilliantly, is that he's not just talking to theologians and bigwigs and stuff, but he's actually talking in terms that are comprehensible to the man and woman in the street. Right. I think inspiring people as well to write in that style. So even while he's in the Wartburg, he's not publishing anything, but people are putting out pamphlets that are articulating his ideas and doing it in ways that echo his mastery of kind of simple, plain German. But it's not just word that is being promulgated, but the image. To give a modern analogy, Luther is not just
你刚才非常精彩地指出了这一点，那就是他不仅是在与神学家和大人物交谈，而且他实际上是在用街头男女都能理解的语言交谈。没错。我认为这也激励了人们用那种风格写作。所以即使在瓦尔特堡，他没有出版任何东西，但人们却在发布小册子，阐述他的思想，并以呼应他那种简单、朴实的德语风格的方式来表达。但传播的不仅仅是文字，还有图像。用一个现代的类比，路德不仅
on Twitter, he is also on Instagram. This is also hugely important in promulgating his message and his image while he is in isolation in the Wartburg is that illustrators are piling in as well. And the inspiration for this is Lucas Cranach, who is Frederick's court painter in Wittenberg, who has become a very good friend of Luther and who right from the beginning has played a key role in branding Luther. And there's a brilliant book called Brand Luther by Andrew Pettigree that explores this wonderfully. And Cranach is a master of everything visual. So even the pamphlets and books that Luther is putting out, it's Cranach who frames them. So he gives them a kind of distinctive binding so that they will stand out on the bookstore. And the font and the lettering
在推特上，他也在Instagram上。这在他在瓦尔特堡隔离期间传播他的信息和形象方面也极其重要，插画家们也纷纷加入。而这背后的灵感来源是卢卡斯·克拉纳赫，他是维滕贝格腓特烈的宫廷画家，他成为了路德的好朋友，并且从一开始就在塑造路德的品牌方面发挥了关键作用。安德鲁·佩蒂格雷写了一本精彩的书叫《品牌路德》，对此进行了美妙的探讨。克拉纳赫是视觉艺术的大师。所以即使是路德发布的小册子和书籍，也是克拉纳赫在进行排版。他给它们一种独特的装帧，使它们在书店里脱颖而出。字体和字母
and everything is very clear and precise. So it's a bit like a Penguin classic or something, that you will immediately recognise a pamphlet by Luther if you see it. But he's also doing portraits of Luther. So that portrait of Luther that supposedly didn't burn, it's a famous image of Luther as a monk looking very pious, ascetic. He's got the spirit in the form of a dove over his head. I know what you mean. Yeah. And this promulgates the image of Luther as an accompaniment to his words. People know what Luther looks like. And of course, this would have been harder to do in an age before printing, wouldn't it? You wouldn't have been able to distribute so many images.
一切都非常清晰和精确。所以这有点像企鹅经典丛书之类的，如果你看到一本路德的小册子，你会立刻认出来。但他也在为路德画肖像。所以那幅据说没有被烧毁的路德肖像，是一幅著名的路德作为修士的形象，看起来非常虔诚、苦行。他的头顶上方有鸽子形状的圣灵。我知道你的意思。是的。这传播了路德作为他文字伴侣的形象。人们知道路德长什么样。当然，这在印刷术出现之前的时代会更难做到，不是吗？你不可能分发这么多图像。
Of course, completely. Let alone so many texts. Yes, absolutely. Yes. And while Luther is in the Wartburg, Cranach teams up with Melanchthon, who is the very young professor of Greek, and they publish a strip cartoon. So it's 13 woodcuts that contrast the life of Christ with the lifestyle of the Pope, very much to the- To the detriment of the latter. To the detriment of the Pope. But even more than that, they really pile in with abusive cartoons. So Carlos Eyre, who's written a brilliant survey of this entire period called, tellingly, Reformations.
当然，完全是这样。更不用说这么多文本了。是的，绝对是。当路德在瓦尔特堡时，克拉纳赫与非常年轻的希腊语教授梅兰希通合作，他们出版了一本连环画。那是13幅木刻版画，将基督的生活与教皇的生活方式进行了对比，非常……对后者不利。对教皇不利。但不仅如此，他们还真的用辱骂性的漫画进行了猛烈抨击。所以卡洛斯·艾尔，他写了一本关于整个时期的精彩调查，书名很有深意，叫《宗教改革》。
So the idea that there are multiple Reformations. I mean, he says the evangelicals, so the followers of Luther, invented the satirical cartoon and they use images as a medium of dissent and polemic on a scale that has never been paralleled in history and in these cartoons luther is the hero and his opponents are objects of ridicule right and unsurprisingly because luther is the inspiration for this there is a lot of excrement in these cartoons yeah they're incredibly scatological aren't they so there's one famous one where the devil is shitting out monks he's excreting monks thanks for that tom but there's another one that carlos air writes about which targets johann cocleas the humanist who had been chatting to luther at firms and. And I'll read as description of
所以存在多种宗教改革的观点。我的意思是，他说福音派，也就是路德的追随者，发明了讽刺漫画，他们以历史上从未有过的规模将图像作为异议和论战的媒介。在这些漫画中，路德是英雄，而他的对手是嘲笑的对象。没错，而且不出所料，因为路德是这一切的灵感来源，这些漫画中有很多排泄物。是的，它们非常淫秽，不是吗？有一幅著名的漫画，魔鬼在拉出修士，他在排泄修士。谢谢你的解释，汤姆。但卡洛斯·艾尔写的另一幅漫画针对的是约翰·科克莱乌斯，那位在沃尔姆斯与路德交谈过的人文主义者。我会读一下对它的描述。
it. One of the most obscenely outrageous of all reformation images, the very epitome of smear tactics, reduces the work of Johann Cocleus to fecal matter. In this image, the devil defecates into Cocleus' mouth and Cocleus in turn excretes books out of his rear end. As devils gleefully dance in celebration of this process, a monk and a prince pick up the books and a crowd of bystanders, some covering their noses, look on in disgust. Yeah, I'm looking at the image now. I mean, you've described it very fairly. I mean, this is literally what happens. A horrendous devil is opening his bowels into the mouth of this bloke and then he himself is, as you say, excreting books. Nothing is left to the imagination whatsoever.
“这是所有宗教改革图像中最淫秽、最令人发指的图像之一，是抹黑战术的缩影，将约翰·科克莱乌斯的工作简化为粪便。在这幅图像中，魔鬼排泄到科克莱乌斯的嘴里，而科克莱乌斯反过来从他的后部排泄出书籍。当魔鬼们欢快地跳舞庆祝这一过程时，一名修士和一位王子捡起这些书籍，一群旁观者，有些人捂着鼻子，厌恶地看着。”是的，我正在看这幅图。我的意思是，你描述得非常公正。我的意思是，这确实就是发生的事情。一个可怕的魔鬼正在把他的肠道排泄到这个家伙的嘴里，然后他自己正如你所说，在排泄书籍。没有任何想象空间。
And we are familiar with this, with our own social media, that abuse and abusive images become more and more abusive because there's a kind of tidal wave, I suppose, of excitement that people who feel themselves to be part of a movement get gathered up on. And if you have the means to propagate your opinions and your hot takes by means of tweets or images or whatever, then you take it. And of course, the consequence of that in turn is that maybe the people who've inspired it can be left behind. And this is particularly the case if, like Luther, you've been effectively the equivalent of being kicked off social media. Yeah, locked up with the devil, throwing nuts around.
我们对这一点很熟悉，在我们的社交媒体上，辱骂和辱骂性的图像变得越来越过分，因为有一种兴奋的浪潮，我想，那些认为自己是运动一部分的人被卷入其中。如果你有手段通过推文或图像或其他方式传播你的观点和热点评论，那么你就会利用它。当然，随之而来的后果是，激励它的人可能会被抛在后面。如果像路德一样，你实际上相当于被踢出了社交媒体，情况尤其如此。是的，被关起来和魔鬼在一起，到处扔坚果。
Yes, exactly. And so the consequences of this, while Luther is in the Wartburg, are very visibly seen in his great base in Wittenberg. So in Wittenberg, while he is away, people are inspired by the image of him standing up to the emperor and to the pope. And the monks and nuns in Wittenberg start to leave their cloisters and abandon their vows. And some of them even get married. And there's this sense that monasticism in Wittenberg and beyond is starting to implode. And students, and again, this is something that we are familiar with as well, that they get caught up in the excitement
是的，完全正确。因此，当路德在瓦尔特堡时，这一切的后果在他在维滕贝格的大本营中清晰可见。在维滕贝格，当他不在时，人们受到他对抗皇帝和教皇的形象的激励。维滕贝格的修士和修女开始离开修道院，放弃他们的誓言。他们中的一些人甚至结婚了。有一种感觉，维滕贝格及其他地区的修道主义开始崩溃。学生们，同样，这也是我们所熟悉的事情，他们被兴奋感所感染，
of it all. And they start targeting masses, they start smashing images in churches, and they start targeting veneration of the Virgin and the saints. And it really starts kicking off in December 1521, so in the build-up to Christmas. And the guy who takes the lead is Luther's friend and admirer, Andreas Karlstadt, who is the guy who is the chancellor, who had accompanied Luther to the great debate with Johann Eck in Leipzig and had always been a kind of restrained and sober scholar, but he now emerges as a kind of firebrand. And again, it's kind of like the highly respected scholar who suddenly goes berserk on Twitter, abusing people left, right and centre. Yeah, that's exactly what I was thinking.
他们开始针对弥撒，开始砸毁教堂里的图像，并开始针对对圣母和圣徒的崇拜。这一切在1521年12月，也就是圣诞节前夕真正开始爆发。带头的人是路德的朋友和崇拜者安德烈亚斯·卡尔施塔特，他就是那位校长，曾陪同路德参加与约翰·埃克在莱比锡的伟大辩论，一直是一位克制而清醒的学者，但他现在变成了一个煽动者。这又有点像那位备受尊敬的学者突然在推特上发疯，到处辱骂人。是的，这正是我所想的。
So I was thinking the comparison is obviously with the great sort of upsurge of kind of capital E enthusiasm in the last five to 10 years and activism and sort of the talk of social justice and stuff. And you would have people who previously would be very boring academics who suddenly find their voice. And then, of course, they're playing to the gallery, aren't they? So they self-radicalize. Yeah. And they get the likes and they want more likes. And the more likes you get, the more radical you become. And I think Kulchnat is the first example of this happening, really. He's the primal example of the angry academic getting cross about Brexit on Twitter.
所以我认为这种比较显然是与过去5到10年里那种大写的“E”热情、激进主义以及关于社会正义之类的讨论的激增相呼应。你会发现那些以前非常无聊的学者突然找到了自己的声音。然后，当然，他们在迎合观众，不是吗？所以他们自我激进化。是的。他们得到了点赞，他们想要更多的点赞。你得到的点赞越多，你就变得越激进。我认为卡尔施塔特是这种情况的第一个例子。他是那种在推特上对英国脱欧感到愤怒的愤怒学者的原始例子。
So in December, he preaches a whole series of fiery sermons and he whips the students in Wittenberg up who go on the rampage, destroying images and pulling down altars and overtly menacing priests who are celebrating mass in the traditional way. And on Christmas Eve, there's a kind of enormous riot across Wittenberg, breaking into churches, destroying images. And on Christmas day, rather than apologizing for this, Karlstead doubles down. So he holds this festive celebration and he is making a whole series of points. So he does it not in the traditional vestments, but in a kind of plain cloak. He is not turning away from the congregation towards the awesome mystery that is at the heart of the Mass, but facing the congregation. He is speaking the word of in their mouth because this whole idea that the laity are not qualified to approach it let alone touch it i mean this is a shocking shocking blasphemy yeah and he gives them wine which is a very hussite thing to do it's a very overtly heretical thing to do karlstadt is going straight in. He's doing the whole thing. And just for good measure,
所以在12月，他发表了一系列激烈的布道，煽动维滕贝格的学生们横冲直撞，摧毁图像，推倒祭坛，并公开威胁那些以传统方式举行弥撒的牧师。在平安夜，整个维滕贝格发生了一场巨大的骚乱，闯入教堂，摧毁图像。在圣诞节那天，卡尔施塔特不仅没有为此道歉，反而变本加厉。他举行了这次节日庆典，并提出了一系列观点。他不是穿着传统的法衣，而是穿着一件普通的斗篷。他不是背对着会众，面向弥撒核心的敬畏奥秘，而是面对着会众。他用他们的语言说出圣言，因为这种认为平信徒没有资格接近它，更不用说触摸它的想法——我的意思是，这是一种令人震惊的亵渎。是的，他给了他们葡萄酒，这是一种非常胡斯派的做法，这是一种非常公开的异端行为，卡尔施塔特直接开始了。他做了所有这些。而且为了保险起见，
in the new year, he marries, and the person he marries is a 15-year-old girl. Well, he's all in. He's all in. He's all in. And the Wittenberg magistracy, they back him. So on the 24th of January, 1522, they basically say that the illegal service that Karlstadt had celebrated on Christmas, that this is brilliant, that this should be the model, that all private masses should be banned, that all religious images should be removed from Wittenberg's churches. And they give a date in February, 1522, when all of this has to be done. And a mob duly goes on the rampage through Wittenberg and they haul out every remaining image, icon, whatever. They burn icons that are made of wood. The stone ones, they have stone images of Christ, stone images of the Virgin.
在新的一年里，他结婚了，他娶的是一个15岁的女孩。好吧，他全心投入了。他全心投入了。他全心投入了。维滕贝格的市政当局支持他。所以在1522年1月24日，他们基本上说卡尔施塔特在圣诞节举行的非法仪式非常棒，这应该成为典范，所有私人弥撒都应该被禁止，所有宗教图像都应该从维滕贝格的教堂中移除。他们给出了1522年2月的一个日期，届时所有这些都必须完成。暴徒们如期在维滕贝格横冲直撞，他们拖出了所有剩余的图像、圣像等等。他们烧毁了木制的圣像。石制的，他们有基督的石像，圣母的石像。
They smash off the heads and break off the arms and celebrate. And it's all great fun. So, Tom, a couple of things strike me about that. One is obviously the thing that will have struck loads of listeners, which we don't want to labor too much, which is the impulse to destroy images, to tear down statues and stuff is something we're obviously very familiar with. And it's remarkable how enduring it is in human history. Just a question about destruction and removal of religious images and statues.
他们砸掉头，折断手臂，欢呼雀跃。这真是太有趣了。所以，汤姆，有几件事让我印象深刻。一个是显然会让很多听众印象深刻的事情，我们不想过多纠缠，那就是摧毁图像、推倒雕像之类的冲动是我们显然非常熟悉的。而且它在人类历史上是多么持久，这一点非常了不起。只是关于摧毁和移除宗教图像和雕像的一个问题。
Is that something new? Because obviously there have been lots of examples of it going back to Byzantine iconoclasm. Or is this an enduring anxiety? No, I don't think it is an enduring anxiety. I think it is taken for granted in Latin Christendom. You're right that there were debates in the Orthodox world, but they were centuries and centuries earlier.
这是什么新鲜事吗？因为显然有很多例子可以追溯到拜占庭的圣像破坏运动。还是这是一种持久的焦虑？不，我不认为这是一种持久的焦虑。我认为这在拉丁基督教世界中是被视为理所当然的。你是对的，东正教世界有过辩论，但那是几个世纪前的事了。
Centuries before. So both in Byzantium and in Latin Christendom, the assumption that images are guides and helps maybe to the unlettered, it brings them closer to an understanding of their faith, is deeply, deeply entrenched. Yes. And so this is seen as utterly shocking and blasphemous. And of course, the blasphemy of it is, I think, part of the fun and excitement. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Of course. You know, blasphemy in itself, they don't see it as blasphemous. And of course, the blasphemy of it is, I think, part of the fun and excitement. Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course. You know, blasphemy in itself, they don't see it as blasphemous, of course.
几个世纪前。所以无论是在拜占庭还是在拉丁基督教世界，认为图像是向导，或许对文盲有帮助，能让他们更接近对信仰的理解，这种假设是根深蒂固的。是的。所以这被视为极其令人震惊和亵渎。当然，我认为这种亵渎本身就是乐趣和兴奋的一部分。是的，是的，是的。当然。你知道，亵渎本身，他们并不认为这是亵渎。当然，我认为这种亵渎本身就是乐趣和兴奋的一部分。是的，是的，是的，当然。你知道，亵渎本身，他们当然不认为这是亵渎。
They see it as entirely justified. They see the presence of these images as malign in exactly the way that people toppling the statues of Confederate generals or Bristol slavers do. But clearly, there is a kind of excitement in it as well. Of course. And it would be foolish to deny that. and i've got another question so my other question is so the wittenberg authorities have given a date right and they have allowed this to happen doesn't this speak to the point that the reformation happens at a particular moment in time but it also happens at a particular moment in time, but it also happens at a particular place in Europe. Because isn't there an argument that only in the Holy Roman Empire, where authority is so decentralized and where local institutions have so much power, could this have happened? It's
他们认为这是完全正当的。他们认为这些图像的存在是恶意的，就像那些推倒邦联将军或布里斯托尔奴隶贩子雕像的人一样。但显然，其中也有一种兴奋感。当然。否认这一点是愚蠢的。我还有另一个问题，所以我的另一个问题是，维滕贝格当局给出了一个日期，对吧？他们允许这种情况发生，这难道不是说明宗教改革发生在特定的时间点，但它也发生在欧洲的特定地点吗？因为难道没有一种论点认为，只有在神圣罗马帝国，权力如此分散，地方机构拥有如此大权力的地方，这种情况才可能发生吗？这
much harder to imagine it happening, let's say, in England. Well, unless the central authority decides that they want to do it. Exactly. Which is, of course, what will happen there. But of course, what will happen, but it can only happen in this bottom-up way, in the Holy Roman Empire and Switzerland. So Geneva. Which is the other great place in the Reformation,
很难想象它发生在英国。嗯，除非中央当局决定他们想这样做。完全正确。这当然就是那里会发生的事情。但当然，它只能以这种自下而上的方式发生在神圣罗马帝国和瑞士。所以日内瓦。这是宗教改革中另一个伟大的地方，
which are the two most decentralized, localized polities in Europe. Yeah. So it can obviously happen in independent cities and Geneva, where Calvin will establish his regime is the obvious example of that. But as we will see in the next episode, there are places within the Holy Roman Empire where these regimes, these kind of iconoclastic regimes will seize control. But of course, Dominic, the magistracy in Wittenberg is not the ultimate arbiter of what should be done. The ultimate arbiter is Frederick the Wise. Right, the Elector of Saxony. Who has been backing the Reformation up to this point.
这是欧洲两个最分散、最本土化的政体。是的。所以它显然可以发生在独立的城市，而加尔文将建立他的政权的日内瓦就是这方面的明显例子。但正如我们将在下一集中看到的，神圣罗马帝国境内有一些地方，这些政权，这些破坏圣像的政权将夺取控制权。但当然，多米尼克，维滕贝格的市政当局并不是最终的仲裁者。最终的仲裁者是“智者”腓特烈。没错，萨克森选帝侯。他一直支持宗教改革到目前为止。
But he's still got his relics. Yeah. And he's not very happy about this. And so he basically says to Luther, I think, you know, it's going too far. You should come out and sort this out. And Luther, who initially had given his backing to Karlstadt, he now also feels that this has gone too far. So Karlstadt is moving towards a position that Christ is not present in the bread and wine of the Eucharist. Luther always
但他仍然保留着他的圣物。是的。他对此并不高兴。所以他基本上对路德说，我想，你知道，这太过分了。你应该出来解决这个问题。而路德，最初支持卡尔施塔特，现在也觉得这太过分了。所以卡尔施塔特正走向一种立场，即基督并不存在于圣餐的面包和酒中。路德一直
thinks that Christ is present. And Luther is not opposed to churches being beautiful and having images in them in the way that Karlstadt has. And so Luther writes to the elector and he says, Satan has come among the children of God. They've gone too far, that they have misunderstood the purposes of God, that they are being seduced by the devil and they are breeding anarchy. On the 6th of March, he reappears in Wittenberg. He's bearded, he's still dressed as a knight. It's clear that the old monkish Luther has gone for good. But in every other way, he is turning back the clock. All the old way of doing things that Karlstadt had abolished, Luther now reinstates.
认为基督是存在的。而且路德并不像卡尔施塔特那样反对教堂变得美丽并拥有图像。所以路德写信给选帝侯，他说，撒旦已经来到了上帝的子民中间。他们走得太远了，他们误解了上帝的旨意，他们被魔鬼诱惑，正在制造无政府状态。3月6日，他重新出现在维滕贝格。他留着胡子，仍然穿着骑士的衣服。很明显，那个旧的修士路德已经一去不复返了。但在其他所有方面，他都在倒转时钟。卡尔施塔特废除的所有旧做法，路德现在都恢复了。
And although obviously the ruined images can't be replaced, those icons that do remain are protected from vandalism. And Luther does what he can basically to completely unpick the reformation that Karlstadt has introduced. And he turns on Karlstadt with the fury and venom that is so Lutheran. And basically, Karlstadt is forced out in disgrace. And it seems that Luther has taken back control of the reformation. But of course, he hasn't. Tom, is that Luther swinging or is he being consistent? In other words, is he swinging because he's lost control of the revolution and also his political patron is in danger of
虽然显然被毁坏的图像无法更换，但那些幸存的圣像受到了保护，免受破坏。路德基本上尽其所能完全拆解了卡尔施塔特引入的宗教改革。他以路德式的愤怒和恶毒转向卡尔施塔特。基本上，卡尔施塔特被迫蒙羞离开。看起来路德已经重新控制了宗教改革。但当然，他没有。汤姆，那是路德在摇摆不定，还是他在保持一致？换句话说，他是在摇摆，因为他失去了对革命的控制，而且他的政治赞助人也面临着
deserting him? Or is he consistent? Am I being unfair and too cynical? I think he is swinging back. I think he's very, very anxious not to lose Frederick's patronage, not just for selfish reasons that Frederick is protecting him, but also because he feels that Frederick has been appointed by God as the guardian of the Reformation and that its future would be threatened were Frederick to turn on it. But I think there's also a strong element of pique. It is a bit like Elvis coming back from the draft and discovering that things have moved on and that new types of music are being developed. So likewise, Luther is resentful that Karlstadt, who he's always seen as his number two, his deputy, has taken the lead. So I think that's
抛弃他的危险？还是他是一致的？我是不是太不公平、太愤世嫉俗了？我认为他是在回摆。我认为他非常非常焦虑，不想失去腓特烈的赞助，不仅仅是因为腓特烈在保护他这种自私的原因，还因为他觉得腓特烈是被上帝任命为宗教改革的守护者，如果腓特烈背弃它，它的未来将受到威胁。但我认为这里也有很强的赌气成分。这有点像猫王从军队回来，发现事情已经变了，新的音乐类型正在发展。同样，路德也对卡尔施塔特感到不满，他一直把卡尔施塔特视为他的二把手、副手，却抢了风头。所以我认为这是
absolutely a part of it. But the thing is that Luther cannot now impose himself on the Reformation in the way that he had done before he'd vanished into the Wartburg. So that word that Carlos Eyre uses, reformations, I mean, we are now starting to look at multiple different ways of, the Reformation is becoming a debating ground of opinions as well as of beliefs. The consequence of this is that there are people who are going well beyond Luther. This man who has been the great revolutionary up to this point, he is revealing himself now to be a reactionary right and essentially for the rest of his life luther will be with the sides of reaction rather than with the sides of reform trying to keep a lid on what he has created trying to slow down the revolution yeah that he has inaugurated and
绝对是其中的一部分。但问题是，路德现在无法像他在消失在瓦尔特堡之前那样将自己强加于宗教改革。所以卡洛斯·艾尔使用的那个词“宗教改革”，我的意思是，我们现在开始看到多种不同的方式，宗教改革正在成为意见和信仰的辩论场。这种情况的后果是，有些人走得远超路德。这个一直以来伟大的革命者，他现在揭示自己是一个反动派，没错。基本上，在余生中，路德将站在反动的一边，而不是改革的一边，试图控制他所创造的东西，试图减缓革命，
of course tom in the next episode we will be seeing how this plays out with unbelievably bloody and violent consequences, won't we? We will. A massive political convulsion that rips through the map of Europe. The German Peasants' War, one of the most exciting moments, Tom, in European history. And perhaps Luther's most fascinating and charismatic opponent, Thomas Munzer. Oh, yeah. Who pushes the Reformation to a very, very radical endpoint. Fantastic.
他所发起的革命。当然，汤姆，在下一集中，我们将看到这一切是如何演变的，会有令人难以置信的血腥和暴力后果，不是吗？我们会看到的。一场巨大的政治动荡席卷了欧洲地图。德国农民战争，汤姆，欧洲历史上最激动人心的时刻之一。也许还有路德最迷人、最有魅力的对手，托马斯·闵采尔。哦，是的。他将宗教改革推向了一个非常、非常激进的终点。太棒了。
So if you're a member of the Restist History Club, or even better, one of our beloved Athelstan members, one of our elect, then you can listen to that episode right away. If you're just back there and made the congregation, I'm afraid you'll just have to wait till Thursday. But one way or another, we will see you next time for the high drama
所以，如果你是《其余皆历史》俱乐部的会员，或者更好的是，我们心爱的埃塞尔斯坦会员之一，我们选民中的一员，那么你可以立即收听那一集。如果你只是回到那里，成为了会众的一员，恐怕你只能等到周四了。但无论如何，我们下次再见，去见证
of the German Peasants' War. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
德国农民战争的高潮。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。